congrats on the first four episodes uh
you guys didn't uh you guys didn't crash
the
car that's the look you never know so
we're I I don't think you have to worry
um so season two starts right after
season one ends and I'm curious how much
did you debate that and like maybe
jumping more forward in time like
because you know I was as a I was
curious where are they going to go yeah
yeah uh it wasn't too much of a debate
but you know in the writer room like all
sorts of paths are discussed that we
certainly walked down a few paths that
uh didn't pick up right away maybe
jumped ahead maybe weren't uh past tvas
there like you talk through all that
very quickly we'
realized doing setting up this past
thing did two things for us it helped us
kind of start the structure in place the
snake getting the tail structure that we
wanted for a full season but also it was
where a lot of really rich character
drama was going to happen picking up in
the immediate moments not just for Loki
but also for Sylvie and the TBA uh we
didn't want to P fast forward past any
of that drama of uh Mobius and B15 want
to stop pruning but this is a vast
organization and clearly uh different
people are going to have different
perspectives on on on the the future
of this so it just revealed itself
fairly organically pretty quickly season
1 was a huge success uh season two is so
far fantastic how much are you guys
already thinking or were you thinking in
in the writing of season two we might
actually do a season three do we think
about this and plant seeds or is it sort
of like we just got to do it one at a
time it was similar to season 1 and we
we wanted to tell this story and tell it
well but uh even in season one we
obviously were thinking about where we
were going I would say season one and
season two were developed and created as
like kind of two chapters of the same
book and we felt pretty strongly all of
us involved That season 2 was about
closing that book uh but that there are
many other books on the shelf for this
character and for this
world uh but this what this felt like it
wanted to be the conclusion of these
great things that we set up in season 1
we don't want to constantly leave people
with uh dress a Cliffhangers uh for our
finales when you were working on season
two how much did you did you have sort
of the creative freedom to do whatever
you want and how much was Kevin and
people at Marvel saying you can do
whatever you want but you really have to
include this that did not happen the the
one the one headline we got from Kevin
from season coming out of season 1 was I
love this world I want to see more of it
and I want to meet more people there cuz
it felt like we were dealing with a
smaller uh kind of corner of of this
organization and and from there it
was basically a mandate to go go further
push it further lean more into the drama
lean more into the world and just build
uh and and frankly season one was that
way too like we we've been given a lot
of uh creative freedom and the all the
filmmakers who have come in and
collaborated with us on on the this show
have been given a lot of leeway to kind
of put our mark on it
um we've been telling by the end of this
almost 12 hours of multiversal
time-based
Storytelling we've always seen it as we
are laying the tracks for that and and
where it goes and what other people want
to do with it great but like we've been
given the freedom to tell our story in a
a cool way so I think people are going
to wonder why is Loki time slipping at
the beginning of the
Season uh all will be revealed keep
watching there but that it is it's paid
off there's a you'll learn you will
learn okay got so there is a resolution
coming answer 100% so one of the things
I'm curious about is you have McDonald's
plays a role in in the season in the
first four episodes and I'm curious with
something like that is it product
placement or is it you guys saying where
could she work let's do McDonald's it
start I'll say that look it's it's
product placement it started with us
though we asked McDonald's if we could
do it so it happened in Reverse we in
the writer room and I think this maybe
is out there but like I had a I had a
conversation with Sophia at the end of
season 1 we were sitting on the steps of
the Citadel it was like our last day of
shooting IID kind of just I was asking
all the casts as we were putting
everything in a blend are thinking about
a season two where do you think Sylvie
wants to go after this she jokingly kind
of said I think she'd be hungry months
go by we're in the writer's room we're
trying to figure out exactly where
Sylvia is and it was just sort of that
seedling of an idea of well that's funny
like there it would be funny that
probably while hanging out at Rock's
cart she saw some McDonald's bags coming
back from employees on their lunch
breaks uh and when I want to go try that
but it sort of came about truly through
trying to find a metaphor to tell the
story
of uh wanting a small life a small quiet
life uh where she could explore Free
Will and what that means what does it
mean to live a life what does it mean to
have friends and I think through a
nostalgic lens of McDonald's in the80s I
think we're able to like easily tell
that story to our audience where they go
oh I remember that I remember going
there there for a party I I remember
going and do this I know what it's like
to grow up in a small town it just gave
us a world to do that and the exciting
thing was like McDonald's was all in and
they realized we weren't trying to make
fun of them it was like a real Embrace
of of that kind of nostalgia so did you
get them to pay for that build they
helped and and the bigger thing they
really helped us find they're not like
Marvel they don't have a warehouse of
props and old sets like those pieces
don't exist anymore that the creepy
apple pie tree uh in the background and
the Hamburglar statues and like they
have an archist who helped us like find
all of that stuff through auctions and
like just private people that own um it
was it was a build like on the outskirts
of London we we took over an old Indian
food restaurant and turned it into a
1980s McDonald's uh Loki and Sylvie uh
had after season one there was a lot of
conversation about their characters uh
what can audiences expect from their
from that dynamic in season two so well
so so much of season one is about
identity and finding yourself and
finding your place in the
universe um for both of them and they're
at different places on this like
trajectory we're furthering that and I
think it's about becoming the best
version of yourself uh but that that
cannot happen until you have
grappled with and accepted your past and
who you are uh like like you'll never
become the best version of yourself
without that without that Embrace of of
just all sides all identities of
yourself and so in in one way that was
something that we just wanted to
continue to push in this season to and
for the two of them it's like they had a
real connection I think they started
that Arc and they started that push for
each other by by finding each other by
connecting but I also think there is a
continuing of that tension point of uh
she can't trust Loki can't be trusted
and season two is
like the two of them having to work
through that I guess which I think you
see in that that one scene where where
in episode four where they have that
conversation about you know we are Gods
like there's a there's something to that
about Loki really embracing that and
there's something sad about the fact
that Sylvia in a way needs to be
reminded of that it's a life she hasn't
really gotten to live I I have to I'm
out of time I was just gonna that no no
it's fine I was just gonna say that key
as OB is gonna be a fan favorite he's so
good in the role i' I've said it in
every interview I've done I think he's
quickly going to become a lot of
people's favorite new Marvel character
100% yeah he's fantastic in the role but
and I love that it's not like a gimme
like let's just cast him like for stunt
I mean he's really integral to the SE
and he's
fantastic he he this was a we already
had a great Ensemble and he fit in
perfectly as if he's been there since
season one I yeah 100% Hey listen
congrats can't wait to see episode five
and six enjoy your afternoon I
appreciate
that